we're going to take you now to chicago
where this past weekend at least 52
people were shot eight of them killed in
a wave of violence across the city what
is going on there five shot including a
one-year-old girl
it didn't even make the front pages
we're losing children every single day i
mean this is crazy i mean they didn't
have to kill my son i think people have
just grown up thinking that you know if
i'm if i'm mad at you i'm gonna grab my
gun and shoot you so 52 shot eight dead
in only three days and the city seems
all but numb to an epidemic of violence
there was this motel across the street
from our church that was full of all
kind of illegal activity
and so i went to talk to the owner about
buying it and i never will forget what
he said to me there's a church over
there there's a church over here
and he said what makes you any different
that you're going to be able to do
something about what's going on
i took that personal
i ended up eventually
going on top of the roof of that motel
and staying there for 94 days refusing
to come down
after the recent shooting of a teenage
boy the pastor decided to take a stand
you know to see a young 16 year old boy
with his mouth open his eyes still open
and his body in a white bag zipped up to
his neck
we were able to purchase it and tear it
down and instantly
prostitution went down drug dealing went
down murders went down
it's time to celebrate phase one but
after this weekend monday we get back on
the grind
and we start all over again
starting phase two to build the most
magnificent building you've ever seen on
the south side of chicago
[Music]
and for a very long time you've been
trying to get a community center yes
talk about that so we've been trying to
get this community center up ever since
i went on the roof of the motel and
bought it and purchased and tore down
we've been working really really hard
but you know it's hard to raise money
it's tough to especially for a community
center in a place that's that's needed
um so it's it's been a trying uh
situation one of the main reasons why
it's taking so long is because uh pastor
brooks has this vision
to build the community and center debt
free how much money do you have we have
about seven million allocated already
between pledges and commitments um so we
have a lot we still have a long way to
go another way that that kind of makes
it a little difficult as well
is is people um
they they want to see a finished product
before they sow into it ever since this
hotel has been knocked down 10 years ago
project hood has been grinding and has
been putting in the work we've had
construction classes we've had
entrepreneurial classes you don't have
to wait for the building to be built in
order for the work to begin the work has
already been done the building the
center is going to help us scale the
work that we're doing
america has really lost its focus
i mean we're always talking about racial
issues and racial divides
and we got these ideologies that are
constantly dividing us and splitting us
apart
where in reality
we are serving and we are here being
american citizens and that's what
america is really all about american
citizens coming together from all walks
of life
to see the issues that are going on and
coming up with positive solutions to
solve every problem that we face what
are you going to do about that so i'm
going back on the roof i mean if it
worked the first time let's try it again
so i'm going back on the roof but this
time i'm going to go for 100 days and
this time i'm not going to go by myself
i'm going to get some guests every day
some corporate figures some ceos and
presidents of companies the ceo
challenge where we are challenging ceos
from various companies to come and spend
the night with us join us in our efforts
to build this community center ken growl
is here the ceo of uptake uh data
analytic analytics company you you're
doing one night i'm doing one night
actually tomorrow night to kick it off
oh so you're one of the you're one of
the first uh
the guinea pigs
[Laughter]
i was at the
project hood golf outing uh up north
chicago and unfortunately the day got
rained out but
the pastor was gracious enough to stop
by everybody's table and introduce
himself and explain project hood in
greater detail
the idea behind the community center
and i was so intrigued and so inspired
by what he was trying to do and what
he's trying to accomplish and so for the
last
three weeks i've been trying to recruit
local ceos to come out here and join me
in camping out with the passer on top of
the
the roof here behind me who else is
going to be up there so we got kurt and
don bernanke curt is the ceo of related
management and don bernanke is the
president uh andy who is uh the
president and ceo of uh
sterling bay i believe that our
knowledge is limited and sometimes we
live in bubbles and the bubbles can be
in various different neighborhoods and
so
that gap for me is truly um unidentified
and that is a real reason why i want to
come here is to close that gap of
knowledge
[Music]
good job
these kids did not choose their mother
they did not choose their father
they were born in this area without a
choice
some of these people that are living out
here have never even left the confines
of this street
and so
what project hood wants to do
is to feel the void that they're missing
we're talking about kids that's never
seen a swimming pool we're talking about
young men and young women who want to
work
there's so much violence that goes on
and people don't know how to process
the deaths that are happening in their
families through gun violence we want to
have counseling and trauma centers and
all this stuff that is housed right here
we cannot put destiny in their hands
but this center will definitely put it
in their reach
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
corey brooks
[Music]
juice
[Music]
you know even as i get ready to go up on
the roof i gotta admit my own
insecurities
fear of failure fear of not raising
enough money but the way i'm going to
overcome that is
with a lot of faith
and a lot of encouragement from people
all across america
who believe in what we're trying to do
bringing self-responsibility and
accountability to individuals helping
people to be accountable for their own
lives
there are people who really believe in
what we're doing and it's because of
that it's going to give me the strength
and the motivation even in the face of
wanting to quit and give up and throw in
the towel to keep on going to persevere
stay committed be courageous that's what
it's really all about
you